so you say you've been to therapy before
and what brings you back my brother
1516 years Oh would you want to engage
with him say I don't have a swing you do
I have a new patient I can't tell if
he's bipolar if he has some sort of
dissociative disorder he's paying cash
perfect if he's paying you cash to treat
him for schizophrenia then he certainly
not schizophrenic
excuse me sorry I'm Craig Norman Josh
from Norman's brother well why is it
that you're back in town want to make
sure I never know you heard issues don't
you want to be in contact with him
yourself you know what I think I don't
want to talk anymore this is not a
normal thing for me have you spoken to
your brother yet I have you the josh is
a pretty disturbed individual I've just
been worried about what getting me to
kill someone for you or you'll harvest
my organs oh I think Josh hallucinates
yeah no he hallucinates I have to tell
you something my brother I have seen him
but only in character sometimes he comes
to me as an old homeless woman this is
what I do judge he has amazing command
over his body I can assume a new
character with just a few votes there
are things that could tell you about my
brother that you really wouldn't believe
I'm a horrible person but you need to
see your brother and you need to let him
see that you are real things are
probably so the best of where they are
now
no they're actually pretty bad I think
you're a very lonely person my hand -
it's easy for us to get carried away
[Music]
I do perfectly fine at life oh we all
have our good days who are not bad days
right nice fine long
[Music]
you